what up Paris skomal
you're in Paris too um just before we
start did anybody else enjoy the
negotiations between Loic and Gary right
now I think BT is killing you on
bandwidth prices I know you paying the
full hundred percent on only BBC's just
the line and the bandwidth
ah no it's it's very the partnership
with BT coordinating everything and it
would cost much more than what I said
yeah it's just for like just for pipe
that's what I was Thank You her Gary for
saying that so you yelled at me last
year yeah badly I realize you remember
because we have even put that into the
intro video of a demo video of LeWeb
where where we say that where you say
that we're not community because we
don't take any questions so one this
year we took more questions even though
it's challenging you guys like the more
questions this year yes or no yeah
questions away you know what many people
like the fact that it's very fast pace
and 20 minutes even five minutes yeah
really fast like he doesn't that's how I
like it you know it doesn't if it gets
boring at least it's only 20 minutes
yeah and so it's super fast and then if
you take questions read challenges but
anyway we have only questions for you I
should just shut up and give you to give
me an update first yeah what are you
doing maybe I'm doing tremendous thank
you I mean well I'm not doing that
tremendous I don't know how many of you
follow American football but I am easily
one of the biggest New York Jets fans in
the world
that is actually why I'm even here or
what I do for a living my goal is to buy
the New York Jets and the New York Jets
how do I say this properly
got their faces punched and pretty bad
on Monday night we lost 45 to 3 to the
New England Patriots so it was kind of
nice [ __ ] that guy I'm watching you I'm
trying to make you out I can see you
anyway
so I was happy to get out of America so
I didn't have to deal with the [ __ ]
but um so I'm a little bit upset about
that but things are good I have a
amazing 18 month-old daughter named
Misha who is uh my heart and soul
so that's good family is awesome and
business-wise things are going extremely
well I start a company last year with my
brother AJ Vader vaynermedia we're doing
extremely well we're doing strategy and
community management for a lot of brands
like PepsiCo full service full service
you know Really Trying
you know it's funny I'm almost in a
place where I'm a mix between the last
two people that were on stage
Jeremiah talking a lot about corporate
how we're talking a lot about
entrepreneur I pretty much got the
entrepreneur sensibility down you know
I've been selling you know my first
business when I was five years old was I
went to people's yards ripped out their
flowers ring their doorbell and tried to
sell it back to them
so I have entrepreneur thank you that's
business
low overhead you didn't sit on inventory
very long tremendous profit margin so I
highly recommend it but you know so I
knew that you know I built a small
family liquor store to a sixty million
dollar a year business I understand the
entrepreneur play I've done it very much
as a personal brand it using the tools
that we all talk now personal brand is
really as a bad reputation in Europe you
don't say you're building a person yeah
I understand and it doesn't have the
greatest reputation in the u.s. either I
mean you know you know there's no
denying that Oprah is a personal brand
you want to say it's not or you do you
want to come up with a new term I mean
for example I hate the term social media
I loved web 2.0 I think social medias
[ __ ] everything up I think when big
companies look at the word media they
think it's time for them to talk again
so very much like my thesis was last
year when we hear that we needed to do
more QA it's the same thing of how I
look at social media I think the word
media has completely confused the market
in my opinion this whole social media
world the things we all talk about the
Facebook the Twitter's the tumblers the
C's mix the youtubes whatever it is it's
about listening to me the way I look at
Twitter and and Facebook and all these
other platforms is there the good cop to
all the bad cop stuff that we all do
whether its buying ads speaking a whole
lot promoting our [ __ ] the way I really
look at a Facebook fan page or a Twitter
account for a brand and for myself is
that needs to be the place where you're
a good cop that's where you need to be a
friend that listens and I think the word
media has always been about push right
radio television newspaper that's
pushing forcing I did that for a fact
forcing your message on the consumer
pounding them until submission
you're a genius if you buy a Super Bowl
ad or buy a shitload of billboards
because you're pounding your product and
logo and message down the consumers
mouth to me the place to offset that
maneuver is social it's a place for you
to actually have a pulse I think we're
living through the humanization of
business I blows my mind that the people
in this room are willing to have
communication and relationships with
logos whether it's you know Nike or
Apple or whatever it may be the fact
that you're willing to talk sports to
Nike or the fact that you're willing to
talk about hip hop with brisk iced tea
and you mean it in a human element it's
very interesting to me I kind of look at
it similar to the way people treat pets
right pets are not human beings but we
have very human-like interaction I mean
I don't know about you guys but I know
people that treat pets better than they
treat human beings and I think that um I
think there's something very similar
happening with business and that's kind
of what I'm obsessed with right now
are you going to keep lecturing us or
actually take questions you get to flip
the switch I'm ready I'm ready any
questions about anything you know let's
go it's fine you know no problem no I
you know I just wanted to warm it up
only questions and you keep you keep
talking you're 100% correct I apologize
well I am ready for questions that's
where I should have said so who has a
question I'll take my Mac so you just
you know this is your stage you have two
wonderful hosts don't know but I need my
Mac to just get questions from the
internet
I see so you go ahead yelled at all
right all right as well so well first
question in the room maybe okay here we
go and if you want you can come and you
would help our hostesses because you're
far away here if you have a question or
you can just raise your hand carry we've
heard of the what's your name
my name is Jonathan I'm Charles to them
it's good to see you again how are you
I have a question Jim and great scarf
thank you welcome
we've heard of the tea party a tea party
have you any plans to get into politics
with a wine party yeah thank you so you
know what's funny jatha is that I truly
believe that I was built to be a
politician in a lot of ways right I have
that kind of DNA my problem is is that I
was born in Belarus and in the United
States you can't become president unless
you're born in the United States and for
me to play a game where I can't be the
ultimate winner makes absolutely no
sense
so I find I I don't see myself going
into politics for that reason I don't
want to be like awesome I could be vice
president one day
[ __ ] that thank you
let's go raise them who's got questions
there we go nice hello Gary I'm loránd
are you fine thank you sorry couldn't do
that interview banner no I had a run
here thank you Gary
what is your real feeling about the fact
that you Commerce website could use
social shopping features to make more
business do you think it's real do do
you experienced some real business with
the social platforms so so help me here
are you saying do I think that's some of
the social add-ons on an e-commerce site
the fact that people could act with
other customers and that it could be
leveraged for e-commerce data so I have
a website called Cinderella wine calm
right Cinderella
you know midnight anyway wine calm I
launched the wine at midnight then we
moved it to 9:00 p.m. don't worry I
[ __ ] it up anyway
in their consumers communicate with each
other and very much like Groupon and
gilt groupe and all these deals of the
day phenomenons we have a site that does
that for our wine business now what
happens when you add unlike every other
wine deal of the day site we have a
forum where people talk and when you
open up the case to discussion they
start talking about your competitors why
they're mad at you you know it's amazing
what happens when you can hide on the
internet and not use true identity right
it's why I'm so bullish on Facebook
Connect and real identity because when
you don't have real identity and you're
just a username
like wino 69 it's amazing what you're
willing to say you know it's the same
reason I believe chatroulette didn't
work you know chatroulette didn't work
because there was an enormous amount of
penis in chatroulette right
I believe that chatroulette could have
won if they would have used Facebook
Connect I have very strong beliefs that
if it was really you and your profile
you would keep your pants on you know so
I think it's very fast
it's it's one of the reasons I'm down on
YouTube to be honest with you in general
I think YouTube could be a much better
place if there was real identity in the
comments because the comments always get
lowest-common-denominator
in a place where you can hide behind a
[ __ ] identity these I think that
there's enormous value in real people
talking about your competitors I have no
problem when we open they talk about our
competitors all the time this is not as
good a deal as this site right now
does it hurt maybe that exact deal
absolutely but when you become the
community the residual commerce effect
is substantial the problem is that most
businesses do not have the thick enough
skin the DNA to actually go there
because it's difficult to watch people
insult your products and what scares
people even more send them to your
competitors my belief is it's valuable
though because once you become the
community much like whoo right root
which is a site that inspired me very
much five years ago I don't know if you
guys are familiar was recently bought by
Amazon they have an open community and
those Wooters look at each other they
come back there daily not necessarily
for the deal at the end of the day what
I think is very much missing from our
space and if you're right now tweeting
or or looking at a YouTube video like it
seems like a resume just promise me
you'll put your head up for four
hundredths of a second because this is
the only thing that I really want to say
I firmly believe that this industry
thinks way too much about scaling
everything's always like how do you
scale how do you scale I got asked right
before I got on stage right now Gary how
do you respond to everything I think we
are grossly under estimating the human
aspects of digital business I really
think that when you start layering human
elements on top of I think I'm more
scalable than ever you
how do I do it I [ __ ] try you know
effort is massively underrated and I
think brands and businesses so if you
must start up or you're part of a bigger
company where you can hide behind a logo
where you're not a person like me
because no assistant is ever gonna tweet
or communicate on my behalf
but if you're a logo you can find 30 40
a hundred five hundred passionate people
to become the voice of your brand and
you can engage with every person that
talks about your brand and I believe the
value of that context is very important
when Jonathan when you asked me that
question
I remember you interviewing me two years
ago at Leigh web when I see your face I
already feel something different for you
we've only spent 15 minutes together and
a couple of tweets online but I feel
totally different about you than I do
about these guys because I don't know
them as well yet but now just by saying
these guys I already feel something
different to them and I truly believe
that we are under estimating context
this space is always fascinated and
obsessed with content is king and I
think we massively underestimate the
context especially when there's human
DNA behind it I think that is the
battleground
I think the humanization of a brand is
immensely important and my new book that
that I wrote and spent a lot of time
actually researching not just by going
on gut called the Thank You economy
talks about what starts happening to a
business when they truly care because
I'm gonna tell you something right now
what does not happen at this conference
is enough is talking about the end user
and the end user is the game
and we think about how to trick them to
see more impressions and we think about
how to like get them to understand but
we don't talk enough about how to
actually listen to them and really do
what the [ __ ] they want awesome the
hands are coming let's go there's a lot
of hands up are you guys willing to move
around thanks
hi I'm Giles from brand watch how are
you I'm good I'm good
I'm loving your energy Thanks so you
talked about the humanization of
businesses there's a tension there in my
opinion because if you're trying to
interact with the business and think of
it like in a human way it has to have a
personality so you think Apple it has
kind of a personality right but it's
made up of thousands of individuals or
you have a whole host of other
personality so you've got this kind of
you know how do you how do you how do
you square that up I I think you do it
through training and you do it through
hiring you know it's very easy for me
you know Wine Library you know I'm no
longer there day to day but I want
people walking into that store to feel
like we pick them up the second they
walk in carry them to the wine they want
grab the wine take them to the register
don't charge them take them to their car
kiss them and send them home that's how
I want them to feel right you know
aren't you gonna kind of do you want to
kind of when you say training you're
you're you're implying that you want
everybody to pick up the corporate
message which is is not it's not great
for most people I don't want to be mr.
Apple I want to be your me working for
whoever do you know I mean we're more
than welcome to go out and do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do right but if
you're gonna work for my company you
need to have the ability to talk about
what I want to talk about now
I think the process begins in the higher
income and how would you feel if
someone's about to you tremendous
because I would never work for anybody
and if nobody wants to you know I came
to their attention right there's the
tension there is no but here's what's
interest I want to be on that tension
point you got a really look at it the
comedian I think you're right and
nothing for nothing I have struggled to
hire a lot of people because I've looked
them dead in the face I just let go of a
designer at vaynermedia and I was
letting him go and he said you were
right as we were talking and I told him
when I was hiring him that he shouldn't
work for me because I can taste in my
mouth
that he's too entrepreneurial and him
too much of himself
and he's too strong willed and wants to
do his own [ __ ] and I said you're gonna
be better off doing it yourself so if
you want to come on board I'm not really
in the business to have you come on
board for a year
build it up send you on your way and
whatever but I'll do it because I like
your style and that's what's gonna
happen and that's what happened however
there's a really interesting thing going
on which is that there are a lot more
people especially in America and that's
what I can obviously talk to better
culturally than other places in the
world but I very much see the younger
generation right now much more obsessed
with the work/life balance in their
lives and I just wonder if I didn't have
that one piece of DNA that was so
entrepreneurial and competitive how
happy I would be working 50 hours a week
for the New York Jets talking to
everybody working my easy nine-to-five
or for what should we'll call it candy
bars which I'm obsessed best candy bar
in the world or you know a many three or
four other brands that I think I'm
passionate about what an awesome job
that would be to work for 40 hours a
week 9:00 to 5:00 get out leave no extra
pressure and everyday walking into a
business that I truly believe in and I'm
passionate about and get to interact on
its behalf
with its consumers so I think the reason
you're asking that question and bringing
up the attention is probably your own
DNA could never go there I couldn't
either
but it would be we'd be very remiss to
not recognize the social trends of
people wanting their weekends off not
wanting to work 87 hours a day and those
people I think have become extremely
happy these are almost better pub PR you
know customer service jobs it's just
like you know Louie you're scaring me
you know these are almost better better
jobs of that so I think I think there is
a case of those kind of people being out
there but your point is well-taken I
think the companies have to be aware of
people that may not like that after six
months you know so we can I have a
question set up tag for you if I can be
of assistance we have a Twitter wall up
what we attack but I can do that
afterwards I want to talk to the people
here if they didn't come if you didn't
come and you're watching and you stream
then [ __ ] you you should have been here
so let's ask them these people waited
these people have been here they've
waited a long time so Gary I've just
been setting up this with my team with a
Gary QA hash target so we don't wall
that's gonna self a day if you don't
want to if you want I don't I want to
ask these people raise your hand next 6
p.m.
hey there Gary hello so I see that
you're a big advocate for face to face
yeah teach at USC at the University of
Southern California where a lot of
students are doing work online oh honey
what do you think about work online
what's the role of face to face for
students you're saying they want more
work/life balance how do you see the
work life the online face-to-face tandem
yes so I love face to face right sila
week now they're gonna be distracted by
the wall I like I like face to face
quite a bit on the human element let me
ask you guys a question if I can
distract you from the wall for a second
that's a good one I really I really want
to ask a question if you guys could pay
attention for one second answer this yes
or no how many of you engage with people
via Facebook or Twitter please raise
your hand don't be lazy raise your hand
all right how many of you feel when you
engage that it feels somewhat similar to
sitting at a table and engaging as well
emotionally raise your hand I am of that
crowd I feel that when I talk on I mean
there's a lot of faces I'm seeing here
now of a lot of people that I engage
with but I don't do it personally but
when I see them in an environment like
this humanly I've already got so much
back to that context and feeling real
feeling when I sent a tweet when
somebody says you know haha Gary the
Jets lost our Patriots and I tweet [ __ ]
you I mean it you know and I could feel
it it'd be the same way if I said it to
their face so I feel like you know
there's way too many people that don't
do this stuff that claim that it's not
real oh the kids are getting ruined the
world's getting ruined because we're
doing it all through computer I think
my emotional interaction with people has
scaled dramatically I have many more
relationships I've dramatically more
context and my opinion I think that that
is extremely important and all this
reminds me of is we could all go to the
libraries right now or probably google
it
there was a shitload of people that said
the telephone was gonna ruin our society
that talking on the phone wasn't face to
face that you know and I I just don't
see it it's gonna continue to move
I feel tremendous you know connection to
the people I engage with online and I
wouldn't mind if it was all of it that
being said I'm a super huggy feely
touchy guy and I love meeting in people
in person but I love the fact that like
as I'm boarding a plane I can have an
emotional connection and relationship
with somebody that I could have never
had any other way thanks Louie can you
take the wall down okay I'm gonna go to
my donation I want to see their faces
and are looking at the screen not my
face okay I can't help it I want to look
so I am one donation away from Ashton
Kutcher we passed him how much are we
just passed we just buy good sure how
much how much money are we add oh that's
easy
let me just check that we have raised it
was not about highest number but it's
it's about the let me see here three
thousand ninety thousand dollars but
this is for from foreign members and
it's solo week yeah I will double the
number right now
okay go ahead so just like you know it's
so this season cause scovilles gonna pay
for it yeah services on causes dot-com
slash the web is going to be a hospital
for sure I mean all right hi Gary I'm
Karen Schneider from Austria and my
question to you is because you mentioned
work-life balance
so should companies tweet on the weekend
should they facebook on that way
all of them what about work-life balance
work life balance is is up to every
individual but a business should be
listening 24/7 if if a customer has a
problem or more importantly and I think
we spent way too much time worrying
about the problems how about the
customers that are giving you love you
know how about when a customer says I
had an amazing time at your restaurant
in Austria on Saturday night it was
amazing I think that thanking people for
thanking you is immensely important and
so I think that there's listen there's a
lot of employees who a lot of human
beings out there who are not fortunate
enough to have work-life balance who are
in circumstances where they need to put
food on the table and aren't worried
about buying [ __ ] gadgets they're
worried about putting clothes on their
children who would be thrilled to work
on a weekend something that lightweight
maybe even in their own home because
they can handle it and so I think
there's a lot of people out there that
are willing to do that job to get make
extra money or maybe because they truly
just love to do it I would say 24/7 is
important I do I think the speed of
response changes the dynamic of the
context you know if I said like had a
you know great TV show Glee it was an
awesome episode today and like two weeks
later to like thanks and feel weird I
don't know it loses some of its momentum
hello hi hi Gary which is me Ryan my
name is Ryan Ryan yeah yeah how are you
I'm good how are you awesome
good um I just wanted to I got my
question has a couple of parts first
question is what position did you play
in high school football because you had
I mean I played cornerback until
everybody realized I was dramatically
too small and too slow to be successful
somewhere around 14 I realized I was
much more likely to buy a football team
than to play for one got it okay that's
good I just had to the imagination that
you might be a linebacker or something
just too small man got it DNA all right
gotta execute against it all right good
um so the real question is so you've
been working with brands now and you're
with your media company are you are you
kind of sorry that you've done that are
you or you or what's the state of the
story work sucks right I mean client
work is like having
somebody take a knife and stick it in
your face right it's not interesting
it's a good overheard I gotta remember
that one um you know but I knew what I I
think way too many people do things
without knowing why you know I think too
many people Oh virtual currencies cool
let me start a virtual currency business
or a Mobile's big I need to make an app
or Wow then they follow trends Oh deal
of the day
if Groupon passes on six billion I'll
make a niche one and I'll make a million
dollars I think you have that purpose
for why you're doing what you're doing
so for me I knew why I wanted to start
consulting I felt that I had a
tremendous sensibility for tech startup
entrepreneurship and I didn't really
understand corporate see I'm not very
good at reading and learning I'm only
good at doing it I need to taste it it's
like wine you could read about wine but
until you taste 60 different lines a day
you don't really know it right so I
needed to taste it I knew what was wrong
with corporate I wanted to understand
how they justified it you know I wanted
to understand the politics I wanted to
understand where they spent their money
because I wanted to learn it because
corporate America has a lot of money
right corporate will always spend they
have to so for me I wanted to understand
it and I wanted to reverse-engineer a
product something more scalable
eventually to them and that's what I'm
doing you know I've spent two years I
think the brands that work with us are
very lucky because I'm really giving
them my heart soul and I think it's more
valuable than what they're paying me and
but I feel good about it because I'm
getting what I want which is I
understand
two years later corporate so much more
than I ever could have in any other way
and I know what to do with it and
knowledge is power and for me the only
way I could really grasp knowledge is
living it it wasn't fun I had a lot of
very smart friends email me and say what
are you doing this is stupid like that
seems like a such a massive step
backwards but I very much understood why
I was gonna do it and I'm very happy I
did not to mention I figured out how to
scale it and you know and vaynermedia is
a multi-million dollar business already
and much more profitable than Wine
Library could ever be so you know it's
kind of interesting cool thanks man
thanks hey how are you doing good man
how are you good
tell everybody your name
I'm max hey max yeah and he has an
interesting site it's like so - stylish
kind of like dailybooth but for style
it's interesting you did a good job
thank you I have one question
what's your only one advice for a young
entrepreneur what's my one advice for
you on you ignore my one advice I mean
my biggest advice for an entrepreneur is
if you're truly an entrepreneur if
you're not a wannabe entrepreneur
did you sell something before you were
12 years old so like that already
worries me right like that's like a big
question for me with entrepreneurs but
that's sales so not every entrepreneurs
just sales so I don't necessarily you're
not totally eliminated but you took a
big debt max but you know that being
said if you're a true entrepreneur I
back to that gentleman's point about you
know I kind of felt his fire like you
know it's it's very I could never work
for somebody else if you're a true
entrepreneur I firmly believe that
everybody in this room and everybody
watching on Ustream and 99% of our
society spends way too much time trying
to be better that the things that are
not right oh I'm not a good
I know entrepreneurs that are trying to
learn how to code in Python why you know
what I mean or like oh I need to be
better at design or I need to figure out
how to be a better public speaker like
you Gary
why if my biggest advice to an
entrepreneur would be to not apologize
to just be an entrepreneur if you're a
real entrepreneur then you want to that
you're more than happy to live in your
mom's basement when you're 29 years old
if you're a real entrepreneur you're
more than happy to wear the same
sneakers for the rest of your life
because you're so obsessed with building
your [ __ ]
you know it's so funny I've gotten a lot
of exposure a lot of TV and my friends
now you know Facebook all your high
school friends come out and everybody's
writing on my wall garetty you're so
lucky you were on Conan O'Brien Oh Gary
you're on today's show Oh Gary I read
how big Wine Library became you're so
lucky do you know what I do I go right
back to their wall and say Tom I'm not
lucky Tom let me paint you a picture
you remember senior year of high school
in those four years in college when you
guys
to invite me to go to the Jersey Shore
and I said no it's because I was working
every [ __ ] hour I'm not lucky you're
[ __ ] lucky you went to the Jersey
Shore
you banged some chicks you drank some
beer life was good you're lucky you know
so I would tell you that if you're a
real entrepreneur if you're sitting
right now and you're real entrepreneur
never apologize not to your parents not
the society execute on who you are I
probably do 99% of the world's deeds
poorly there's about four to six things
I do well and all I ever do is really
focus on that LeBron didn't try to
figure out how to do something different
Tiger Woods wasn't like well I suck at
this they [ __ ] focused on what they
were good at if you know what your
naturally good at execute harder against
that that is no question in my mind your
biggest advantage and being successful
because it's naturally already in you
execute against that [ __ ]
who else hey hey how are you is it
working okay you're the guys sitting
right there yeah how are you find you
I'm an SEO I'm a journalist and blogger
from Italy I have three short question
first question should every company on
the world and when I say every I mean
every company in the world engage with
social network and what is the best case
of a social network engaging you so and
what is the worst yes so I mean listen
nothing is always all in or all out
right all the good [ __ ] happens in the
middle gray is the best cover color in
this world you know not black or white
do I think so I think it's the biggest
opportunity brands I've ever had for the
first time in ever brands don't have to
rely on gatekeepers to tell their story
no longer are the Financial Times or the
BBC or CNN or Wall Street Journal
completely in control of the story that
the world is consuming
I think it's an enormous opportunity I
said on garyvaynerchuk.com the other day
social media is not a necessity but it's
one of the greatest opportunities of all
times so I think yes but if somebody
doesn't want to or maybe their brand is
to be secretive or some restriction I
understand I just can't wrap my head
around why you wouldn't want to engage
with the people that actually buy your
[ __ ] you know mainly because you
probably don't believe in the [ __ ]
you're selling you know is usually the
answer the best execution of social I
think is yet to come I don't think any
business has been really built on a
foundation of really giving and then
learning how to monetize I think the
golden study in the u.s. is Zappos in a
lotta way but it was much bigger than
social media their culture was built on
customer service and I believe that's
what social really is at the end of the
day a real opportunity to create you
know context and relationship so I think
Zappos has done a nice job with it but I
don't think I'd like to hope that in
five years
Zappos execution will look like [ __ ]
that brands have gone way past that the
worst case is very easy you know there's
so many bad ones
anybody any brand or business that you
go on their Twitter account right now or
their facebook status update and three
of the last four messages they've sent
out have been selling an appearance or
giving you a coupon or telling you about
an offer they had that [ __ ] so I would
say that all of them Gary can I
interrupt for a second fine
so we have about two thousand and use
freemen this is a really big room by the
way so we probably have half of like
like we probably have like a turn right
here right now
and the next target is Dave Maureen of
path is at 220 donations and we are at
116 you think we you think you can do a
hundred donations at ten bucks each from
3,000 people Oh Dave morons our next
donation yeah we we passed Ashton
Kutcher he's just a souvenir now thank
you you know I would tell you something
and I and I mean this I'm about to say
something and this word I can get into
trouble i guess i'm i actually what i
just did in matching your donation
dollars I'm kind of upset that I did I
got caught up in the moment I'm very I'm
very weird about the whole donation oh
wait I thought you were doing that by
asking your followers to do you know I'm
personally gonna match I know you
shouldn't do that no I'm going to cuz I
like you well thank you you're welcome
know what and and and that wow now I'm
really glad I brought this up I'm very
weirded out by what's going on in in
social donations and I'll tell you why
how many of you raise your hand saw what
happened when six or seven very big
celebrities the other day you know Ryan
Seacrest Lady Gaga Kim Kardashian died
on Twitter until they raised a million
dollars and then they would start
tweeting again raise your hand how many
of you saw that all right so when I saw
that I was very confused because I said
to myself okay here are
multimillionaires right who are taking
away then pitching [ __ ] to their
audience and asking their audience to
give a collective million dollars I
think it is a completely broken how 99%
of the [ __ ] is going down with donations
I
think asking for people to donate
without and listen by the way I have no
context on what you what you do when I
do what you know maybe Kim and Seacrest
in those guys I'd really like to know
how much they gave personally I think
it's very difficult to ask a community
and they're being asked so often I in
listen I want to raise but I'm you know
20 I had somebody hit me up on Twitter
don't worry take the next question don't
worry buddy 5-10 minutes we pick the
winners so if you want to win a ticket
you can still do it I really think we
need to look at a car then and we close
the web phenomenal I think we have a
really interesting issue brewing with
the way we're raising here and I think
it should be looked at and I think
there's a better way to go about doing
it than pressuring your fan base into
supporting it and and I don't think that
that's what you're doing I really don't
but I didn't like the fact that I feel
that I just used a no nation to make
myself look good and you know I've
really enjoyed where I'd been for the
last three years which is somebody
called me out a couple years ago and
said you never do any of this stuff and
I told them to meet me at Starbucks in
New York City and show to my tax return
I think too many people are leveraging
crisis like Haiti and Chile and
donations to make themselves look good
and I think it needs to be looked at
that's all thank you that being said
[ __ ] Dave Boren let's donate okay yeah
I'm just talking yeah I'm just no my
question is um you're engaging to answer
all every solicitation you have but
sometimes I don't know you might be sick
or maybe you want to sleep how do you
manage to stop walking sometimes so yes
I do want to answer all my tweets and
Facebook messages and emails but I don't
not anymore it's just gotten too big the
math has defeated me but I think what we
don't recognize enough in this space is
effort right
I you know effort is you know when you
relationships of people I had a flight
issue with with Leigh Webb I tweeted out
Louis did it he answered me immediately
now we really know each other and we
have a relationship but that effort
meant a lot to me because he didn't need
to deal with my [ __ ] flight issue
three days before this magnificus huge
conference but his effort meant a whole
lot to me maybe more than any time he
pitched me or anything else you know
what I mean I think effort is grossly
underestimated right now in general it's
not talked about enough the reason it
feels like I answer all of them is
because I'm trying but I don't and when
somebody comes out and says ooh Gary
you've changed you think you're a big
shot now two years ago you answered me
every time you haven't answered in my
last two tweets you know whatever before
usually I can even get in there and say
I'm so sorry it must have just fell
through the cracks maybe was bad timing
maybe the Jets lost by forty two points
on Monday Night Football and I didn't
want to talk to anybody in the world
you know usually thirty to fifty people
jump in there come to my defense because
they're like no he answered me an hour
ago or two days ago and I think I think
that's what it comes down to peer so I
think it's it's simply effort and I
think you need to try I think a brand
and a business has no excuse because
they can scale forever because it's logo
I think personal brands have excuses
because they're human beings they're one
person but I think effort is something
that we need to look at more the value
of effort because of that I'm doing it
four or five six seven nine twelve hours
a day and trying when I miss a few or
have a bad string where I'm missing a
few from the same person the community
itself becomes bigger than the
individual supporting that effort Thanks
hi Gary how are you I'm well which my
name is ALS hi Alex
I yell it with the T I yell it yeah for
the team that's really how are you good
you don't know I heal it okay blonde -
OH
yep how are you I'm very well I have a
new media PR agency and every time I
meet with a potential new client they
always ask me how do you measure the ROI
of social media so I would like to hear
your response to that yes so that was
the beginning thesis of how I wanted to
write the new book the Thank You economy
because I know the problem everybody
asks that here's the problem the ROI in
social media is patience right you know
you have to have that DNA to be able to
understand the ROI of social media
the problem with businesses as a
creature is they don't have it right so
you've got a fundamental flaw the way
I've answered that question lately has
been this somebody will look at me
pretty aggressively and say what's the
ROI of social media I respond by saying
what's the ROI of your mother right so I
think anytime you're ever asked what the
ROI of social media is I'd like to
debate the ROI of your mom you know I'm
trying to dissect the ROI of my
relationship with my mom my mom is so
obnoxiously responsible for everything I
have it's inconceivable right first she
gave birth to me that was a very
substantial first start right second
she's the biggest influence in my life I
not only share DNA with her I spent
every moment of my life from the day I
was born till 18 with her because my dad
worked his face off even when we came to
America and had no money so that my mom
could be home with us she's the greatest
mother of all time period end of story
no debate you can tie me with your mom
but you can't beat me she's that
unbelievable right so her Klout score is
a billion right you know she so but
what's the ROI of that really everything
right and and I think it's a silly
question because the word media [ __ ]
it up it did because they understand how
to measure the ROI now that being said I
think it's coming here's what these
companies are waiting for they're
waiting for some establishment that
they've trusted in the past whether it's
Nielsen's
McKinley to give them some [ __ ]
[ __ ] data that they believe in once
it becomes permanent that a facebook
friend is worth three dollars and nine
cents or a Twitter friends worth 67
cents they'll justify in their own minds
what it is and they'll execute against
it the whole thing is straight horseshit
anybody who knows how to run a business
that doesn't understand the ROI of what
having a relationship with the consumer
is that's what social media should be
rebranded to how about relationship with
the consumer that's what it is if you do
not understand what the value the
monetary financial value of having a
relationship with a customer is then you
have no [ __ ] idea what business is
about and so the ROI you can give them
numbers will come up with numbers don't
worry
blondie 2.0 we're gonna get there you
know that I know that Nielsen's is
working on it every day we're gonna have
some [ __ ] [ __ ] number the ROI is
greater than that number I promise you
because all of us know how much money
we've spent with people that we either
know that we were recommended to you
know this is how we buy things
word-of-mouth is the currency of how
people spend their money and that's what
this entire ecosystem is built on I
think the whole thing is laughable at
best anybody who asks it and means it
because they want to stick a hole in it
I think is a losing player who you know
probably a classically trained solid
student that has no feel for markets and
I think the whole thing is kind of
interesting I answer what straight anger
I think you should - great awesome
thank you ready Gary am I done
you want the last one or I would love
the last one okay very very last one
then we have Matthew 10 balm of hano who
invented the Twizy it's a little car
which is awesome yeah which will be won
in in a few minutes last oh nice helmet
thank you very much hi Gary I'm JB from
sumenep and I just wanted to know what
are the key points to you four French
guys trying to expand to the u.s.
actually to the US for a French company
trying to hit who the US consumer yeah
exactly
yes so I mean you know what kind of
product we do a product dedicated to
designers
digital agencies and stuff like that
yeah I mean the only way to do it is the
way to do it whether you're in France or
in the US which is to go directly at the
people who are the buyers
curseth so yeah I mean it's effort right
I mean how do you do it you send emails
or try to find relationships that you
know that know the people you're trying
to get to and you stay up to three
o'clock in the morning and you email
them all I mean you know it's hard work
but the answer is once you understand
who you're getting to who you're and a
consumer is no matter if you have a
start-up iPhone app or your agency or an
agency or CEOs whoever your client is
you should be obsessed obsessed 24/7 365
with trying to get to them and telling
them your story all the other [ __ ]
is horseshit you just need to get to the
person that you're trying to tell your
story to and whatever way you can get
that whether that's hitting them up on
their Facebook page hitting them up on
Twitter it's never been more easy to get
to people than it is today so there
should be no excuse not being able to
communicate now your product has to be
good and I think that's the thing that
most people should pay attention to I'm
gonna leave with this you know content
is king I'm blown away by how many
people are obsessed with marketing or
social media when their product is [ __ ]
if you make a wine and it tastes like
garbage you could have a billion Twitter
followers you're not gonna win thank you
thank you guys sorry
happy holidays hey Gary thanks very much
oh I love yes I will part with this I
don't know about you guys but you know
you know I love to always come up here
and razz with Lois but this has been an
unbelievable conference I think he won't
do it for himself
well he might there's my wife it is your
wife you're right I think we should give
them a round applause it was an
unbelievable year that's that's thank
you but that's too early thanks Gary